hey guys it's evan today i wanted to
share with you
one of the ways that i recognize the
people in my life and it doesn't have to
cost a lot of money to to thank people
and show them that you care about them
and it's really the thought that counts
and there's a lot of creative things you
can do for them
one of my favorite websites that i use
is called fiverr.com it's a funny site
it's basically things that people will
do for five bucks and a lot of times
i'll order things from here that is for
the people in my life if it's for family
members if it's for my staff if it's for
partners that i'm working with so you
can see here if you go to the home page
you'll see things like i will pop in any
message you want in a video for five
bucks so you can have this puppet say
something one of my favorite ones that
i've used recently
is by uh some kids called benny and
millie and this is them and basically
what they do is they sell jokes for five
bucks and uh millie the girl here
she is confined to a wheelchair
unfortunately and their house is not
wheelchair accessible and so they are
trying to raise forty thousand dollars
through fiverr
by selling jokes to people and uh and
raising money to make the house more
wheelchair accessible so i found out
about them and i've been using them
recently to thank the people in my life
and it's five bucks at a time but it's a
highly customized message so i just made
another order they do six at a time up
to six at a time and so uh i ordered six
more
today and these are the people i'm i'm
thanking so stephanie and alex are my
sisters so
uh what they basically do is they stop
to say hey we're making this video to
try to raise money for our house and uh
this is a joke for stephanie from her
brother evan who wanted to say thank you
for being a great sister and then
they'll tell some kind of brother
related joke so i'm doing it for alex my
other sister hayden my son
jane is one of my clients that we had
some fun on twitter uh and then sharon
and tracy were part of my salsa business
and so it's just a great way to thank
and recognize the people in your life
all the responses i've gotten so far
have been
we love these kids it's so adorable
thank you so much and it doesn't take a
lot of time it doesn't cost a lot of
money it's only five bucks they they put
a video on youtube for you and just a
great way to thank people and do a good
thing at the same time and you know part
of my business is giving back and
helping entrepreneurs and i think part
of every business should be to help
others and have some kind of
responsibility so i love this message
it's a great way for these guys to raise
some money for me to recognize the
people in my life and to do a good thing
uh and so if you're ever looking for
ideas of ways to thank people that don't
have to cost a lot of money just go out
check out fiverr.com see what shows up
here you can dig deeper sometimes the
fun and bizarre ones are are interesting
and you might stumble across something
like this and uh it makes everybody feel
good and you're doing a good thing it
doesn't cost you a lot of money anyway
those are my few minutes on how to do
something good for people that doesn't
cost a lot of money if you guys enjoy
this please leave a comment below i
really love seeing those come in if you
have a question let me know i'd be happy
to answer it for you
and if you liked the video please give
it a thumbs up thank you so much and
i'll see you soon
you